So today we've talked about version spaces. Version spaces are an algorithm for
converging onto an understanding of a concept, even in the absence of prior
background knowledge or an intelligent teacher. We covered the algorithm for
version spaces, where we iteratively refine a general and
specific model of a concept, until they converge down onto one another.
We then talked about using version spaces to address more complex problems.
We've also connected version spaces to older concepts, like incremental concept
learning. Finally we talked about the limitations of version spaces,
such as what to do if there's no single correct concept, or what to do in
the absence of either positive or negative examples. To address these, we also
covered identification trees, which are a different ways of approaching the same
kind of data that version spaces operate on. We'll touch on version spaces and
incremental concept learning again, when we talk about mistake based learning.